là dans l'appart à ce stade on voit où
vont être les choses mais elles sont pas
encore là donc faut les imaginer l'aller
aura une cheminée
le lit nuptial
la cuisine
la baignoire la bouche l'aller aura le
lit invité la table à langer le cinéma
je sais pas bonjour à tous chose promise
chose due on vous fait la vidéo de
l'appartement
j'avais pas l'anglais non mais je
conclus nestor martin lacasse et donc
voilà c'est la suite de notre première
vidéo sur ma chaîne secondaire où on
partage un peu notre passion travaux du
moment ça fait des mois qu'on est dedans
on choisit des meubles ont choisi des
couleurs des matériaux j'en ai une
chance inouïe d'avoir cet appartement de
pouvoir car ce qu'on veut de danser à 20
de chances de ouvrant la vie en plus on
travaille avec une équipe de dingue
ralph qui sont occupés de faire le
design d'intérieur architecture
d'intérieur et tourner la chance de
pouvoir faire ça de a z et bloc party
les fnl pour pour la caméra j'ai bloqué
le
[Applaudissements]
sait je pose à diestar vient de la
personne qui me coupe le temps d un
suivi des chantiers c'est moi qui dira
tout au niveau intérieur mon équipe il
avait fait un bon boulot je peux mettre
les bars de la cuisine normal il veut
nous aider
ils essayent de nous aider en plus la
met tout en place
non seulement il est vraiment utile
merci les verts vous déchirer au
comptoir
hu a trait à fond
là et la violence vis de nous aider
mais nous allons tester une bonne
chose qui me fait condamner en fr
qu'est-ce que tu as koupèla vous le mot
dur la ga les éclaireurs fallait pas
qu'on c'est pas possible je crois j'ai
touché un fil cette phase on trouve
ces deux et vous pas laissé faire parce
que sinon on va pas arriver à la phase
le reste est ce qu'elle sait faire avant
un coup de main
mais je crois qu'on va plus à l'arrière
et à l'avant
[Musique]
voilà la moldau on a déménagé ce matin
ça va
aller je continue moi
le début des toilettes on va s'évacuer
le caca bientôt ce truc sera dégueulasse
mais derrière
j'ai avec le thème est d'accord
c'est quoi tes goûts de hauteur de
bureaux toi
c'est vraiment sûr nous y on apprend pas
la chef des mines donc là on est en
train de discutez la longueur des
poignées de portes de la caf oui je sais
pas mais ce genre de discussion les
reposes c'est parti pour quelques
secondes de délicieuses publicité on se
retrouve juste après north bay pn permet
non seulement du navire en toute
sécurité sur tous les réseaux et public
mais également de contourner tout légers
aux restrictions très simplement et
rapidement contourner les règles en
accédant à des jeux vidéo des films des
séries les programmes tv à des tarifs
avantageux en changeant votre
localisation ou simplement avant tout le
monde comme si vous étiez partout dans
le monde devenait rebelles et en plus
noir epn bloque les pubs et les malwares
génial
morceaux ouais
donc pas écrit que moi j'aime ça ça et
ça tout hasard
donc bienvenue dans notre chambre on a
fait une star je sais pas comment la
beauce à l'embellie va venir ici et donc
on sera
super explications on sera dans l'arche
voilà les premiers coups de pinceaux de
notre oeuvre d'art sur la cheminée buena
pour toute la nuit je crois tu peux nous
dire ce que t'as inspiré ce motif
baromètre montage d'accra qu'on a fait
en premier sur ipad avec de très bonnes
peinture found ball les meilleurs
parlant ça va tenir au moins quelques
siècles
et voilà la première connerie cette
giclures de rose en plein milieu de ce
magnifique ap la move to cash et [ __ ]
ça ces artistes comme ça ta gueule tâche
arrivé à l'étape où il ya certaines
nuances de couleurs qu'on n'a pas donc
je vais essayer de faire le mélange
c'est pas ça va donner donc un peu de
rose pape étant une pointe de jaune et
un petit nuage de bois
la pierre couleur de l'histoire des
couleurs c'est un belge caca d'oie je
vous le déconseille dans votre habitat
en vrai l'objet le plus cool c'est ça
j'ai insisté pour l'avoir mais vraiment
je suis très famille
[Musique]
ici ça va rester blanc parce que là va y
avoir une télé en vrai on se concentre
maintenant sur les hauteurs et finir
faire des petits dessins un petit peu à
droite à gauche
voilà trois heures du matin on va pas
tout vous montrer parce que normalement
le résultat doit être dévoilé dans une
vidéo ultérieure donc affaire à suivre
il le voit si on est dans le futur
bureau sache le studio de vidéos ça a
été fait par l'atelier dur elles ont
tout fait à la main un petit dégradé de
gris comme un affront je suis
extrêmement content et le viol comme ça
qui sont reliés par rapport aux murs qui
quand on actionne les télécommandes il
ya des leds derrière les alvéoles qui
vont produire des lumières partout de
différentes couleurs au choix s'avère un
incroyable donc on a pensé cette ce
d'écart avec 2.2 sheeran ici on rate
notre but est de la vidéo à des panneaux
acoustiques la leçon que ça résonne de
recyclage permanent mais ça résonne
énormément l'arrêt est ici aura trois
écrans c'est mon rêve depuis toujours ça
ne sert à rien pour moi mais c'est juste
pour le fiff trois écrans son monde ses
mimiques jaillira un gros plus pour
dessiner sur des feuilles l'ipad et
faire des trucs manuel évaluera la
partie pour martin autres blessées
diminue tous et enfin
la partie elle plus attendus d'ici
d'avoir une grande télé avec le
simulateur vivent simplement parce que
je suis viscéralement à foudre en ce
moment et je vais en faire au max et la
gaine crise
maintenant même dans ce superbe bon fin
de vidéo fin de vidéo fin de journée on
a un peu que la cause ce qu'on est trop
content que ça avance vraiment bien et
la prochaine étape c'est l'appartement
fini j'ai depuis quand même pourquoi on
est fatigué aujourd'hui on a déménagé on
a nettoyé ancien appart c'était long
mais on se plaint pas abbas est parfaite
on a une chance qui est immense que je
monte la taille de la chance ou
malchance co
rendez vous à la prochaine vidéo j'ai
pas comme un sorcier mais sera trop cool
hausse découle andy cole hawes parce que
je suis est radieux
c'est hyper un gars j'en ai plus rien à
[ __ ] je m'exprime comme je suis désolé
mais c'est toi merci à toi et merci à
vous merci en fait toutes les choses de
l'univers et surtout abonnez vous si
vous ne voulez pas rater la prochaine
vidéo
[Musique]